on part à présent à la chasse aux
fausses infos c'est un fointox
[Musique]
un fond intox Anthony Saint Léger et son
écran magique bonjour Anthony
après le décès de la reine Elizabeth II
certaines vieilles fausses informations
je n'arrive pas à me faire au terme
d'infox pardonnez-moi ils ont refait
surface le premier exemple ce soir et
bien il est censé montrer l'une des
facettes de sa personnalité le sens de
l'humour de la monarque et sa malice
effectivement regardez cette photo que
l'on a pu au revoir resurgir donc sur
les réseaux sociaux on y voit un garde
anglais censé être son époux Philippe
devant lequel donc passe la reine
Elizabeth II et c'est parce que le
prince a Philippe serait vêtu ainsi
qu'elle aurait ce sourire qu'elle
arborait ce sourire d'où son étonnement
et sa surprise donc des commentaires de
nous dire justement que le prince
Philippe était en temps de lui faire une
blague un français Philippe facétieux
donc pour amuser son épouse et cet autre
lors de donc ces deux commentaires qui
ont été publiés juste après le décès de
la reine et cet autre nous dire donc
d'aimer à se rappeler justement cette
image d'une reine souriante avec cette
anecdote le souvenir donc d'une reine
souriante et des doux donc à faire le
tri du vrai du faux et bien la réponse
elle va nous venir Raphaël des abeilles
et oui je vous en parlerai un petit peu
plus on va d'abord se concentrer sur la
photo en elle-même oui il s'agit bien du
prince Philippe mais ça n'a rien
d'étonnant ou pour la simple et bonne
raison que le prince est Philippe était
colonel des grenadiers Gordes l'un des
régiments d'infanterie de l'armée
britannique on le retrouve d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises dans des apparitions
publiques vêtues de cette uniforme ici
vous voyez le tweet de grenadier Garde
publié à l'occasion de son anniversaire
en 2018 on le voit ici également aux
côtés de l'arène ou encore ici une photo
d'archives en étant
1988 et en premier plan et bien c'est le
prince Charles à l'époque le roi Charles
III désormais donc oui il s'agit bien du
prince Philippe ce n'est donc pas pour
cela que la reine à ce sourire non si la
reine a ce sourire et bien c'est parce
que cette photo prise donc le 15 avril
2003 lors d'une cérémonie sur les
pelouses du château de Windsor on a
droit à Christian de Happy tout
simplement parce que voici les coulisses
un essaim d'abeilles à semer la panique
et la zizanie lors de cette cérémonie on
voit toujours ses clichés de Christiane
et vous voyez ici que en apiculteur est
en train d'enlever les seins d'abeilles
en dessous d'une des chaises des invités
donc rien à voir avec le
l'uniforme prétendument de du prince
Philippe et ce sourire de la reine
Elizabeth II 3e et dernier exemple
Antonia cliché censé représenter
Elisabeth II et son époux tous deux
s'inclinant devant un chef d'État
effectivement on va le regarder ensemble
alors ce sera le deuxième un exemple si
je peux me permettre de vous corriger on
va regarder effectivement la photo en
question regardez cette publication qui
affirme donc que on voit ici le prince
Philippe et la reine Elisabeth II elle
s'agenouillé en tout cas s'incliner
devant deux autres chefs d'État ce qui
est une entorse au protocole puisque la
reine étant la souveraine et donc la
représentante de Dieu sur terre le
protocole lui interdit de s'incliner
alors qu'en est-il et bien la recherche
d'image inversée elle nous ramène à ce
cliché authentique on est en 1955 et ce
cliché ont le droit à on le doit à
Alfred hasenstein pour un photographe du
Time problème la première visite
officielle de en Éthiopie parce que ce
qui est dit effectivement j'ai oublié de
le préciser c'est que ce serait le roi
d'Éthiopie à laisser l'acier premier et
l'impératrice Menen or la première
visite officielle du couple royal
britannique a lieu en
1965 comme nous cet article cette fois
du New York Times et qui plus est
l'impératrice Menen est décédé en 1962
donc trois ans avant la visite
officielle et le consortium meredit qui
qui gère la version numérique du Time a
été contactée par les Observateurs de
France 24 ils nous confirme bien que
cette photo est issue de leur colique
Sion qui ne s'agit pas du couple royal
britannique sans pour autant nous
préciser est en mesure en tout cas de
confirmer à l'identité des personnes
présentes ici et là merci Anthony
c'était Anthony Saint-Léger info intox
rester avec nous on se retrouve dans
cinq minutes pour un nouveau journal
dans Paris direct
[Musique]